The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, most
everyone's here.
We're still going to take
a few minutes to wait
for the last few people show up.
I don't have a ton
of announcements,
but if you looked
at the syllabus,
you might notice is there are
a couple days where we have,
I think we've got TBD as the
topic, like to be determined.
What I'd like to do is just
take a quick poll from y'all.
Is there anything that you
are interested in learning
about in the creation
of video games
that you either we haven't
talked about in class yet,
maybe we've talked
about it but not
fully, you've looked
at the syllabus
and it's not there
on the syllabus.
Or it's something
that you think is
going to be directly
useful for the games
and you're working on right now.
So just putting that out there.
If there's any topics you
might want to talk about,
learn about, let me know.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: You really,
like, in other classes
you didn't say, really, in
the last class or the last two
classes, say really,
like, what people actually
do in the industry.
PROFESSOR: OK, so yes.
Cool, so what people
do in the industry.
Cool.
You are in luck.
On December 1st and 3rd.
On the first, we're having
a business in games panel.
So two independent
developers in the area
are going to come by and
talk about how they started
their companies,
what do they do,
what's their daily
life, things like that.
And then another
one following that
is the community manager for
Fire Hose Games, Sean Baptiste,
is going to talk to us about
how do they get their games out
in the world, and how they get
people to play their games.
And how do they
engage their fan base.
And how do they even just
create a fanbase in general.
So that's not on the syllabus,
But we will be doing that.
Any other topics?
OK.
I'm going to ask this again in
a couple weeks in case something
pops up, because
you probably haven't
done a lot of technical things
with your game engines yet.
So if there's anything
gaming specific
that you might
want to know about,
either let us know through the
through the video game bosses
email address, or
let us know in class.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Who will be
giving these lectures?
Like, is this open
to-- can you get--
PROFESSOR: I can get people.
So I can get people
who are local,
we've got connections
to local industry.
We've got connections
to the people
who make the tools, in some
cases, depending on the tool.
That's why I'm asking now,
because it gives me time
to fill new gaps.
Also, it might be something
that we can talk to.
So if there's anything
design-related
that you think is
useful for your games
that we haven't
talked about yet,
and you don't see it on
the schedule, let us know.
If there's anything
technical related,
Drew can come up
and say something.
The other thing we
can do is if there's
anything that you
want to do, or if you
want to set up
office hours in class
to talk about a certain
topic for your games,
specifically technical issues,
technical questions, that's
what Drew's here for.
To come and talk with your
group as a whole, or just
individual members in your
group to talk about the issues
that you have.
So we can do that during
class, during our schedule, one
and a half to two hour
work-in-class periods,
or you can set up work
office hours with him.
Just give people
couple more minutes.
The attendance sheet
is moving around.
So is everybody sitting
with their teams right now?
It looks like-- I'm going
to go across and just
try to figure out which
of these teams are.
So it's the snap team,
is everyone here?
Two, OK.
Which team, this is
forecast-based futures
over here, right?
How far do you go?
John, are you in this team,
or are you in the next team?
Cool.
Next team over,
which team are you?
Cholera?
No.
You're in cholera team?
Were you the island group?
Animal Crossing one.
Cool.
And then in the front
here we've got heat wave,
and the back it's the
other cholera group.
OK.
I did not get a chance
to play your game.
But I will eventually.
So there's going to be a
little bit of interactivity
in the talk.
I've given this talk before.
I rewrote the lecture,
and I haven't given it
since I rewrote lecture,
so we'll see how it goes.
They're my backup to let me
know if I forgot anything.
There will be some
reading on this
I'm going to put into Stellar.
So if you are
interested in the topic,
if you have more
interest in the topic
and you want to
read the reading,
I would highly
recommend it, especially
if you think you're going
to be in a leadership
position in the future, or any
kind of managerial position.
Or you're interested
in just psychology,
and how people talk to each
other and work together.
So our three main topics,
this will actually
be pretty quick on this lecture.
We're going talk
about, we're going
to do a really quick
review of Agile.
We're going to talk
about team dynamics,
and we're going to talk about
how do distributed Agile
teams perform?
So what are some of
the best practices
they have for performing?
And then you're going
to work in class.
You'll have at least two
hours to work in class today,
a little more than that.
So agile processes.
If you forget everything
in this class,
you got into the real world
and somebody asked you,
what is agile?
I hope you remember this part.
Iterative development.
Does anybody
consider what they're
doing iterative development
on their projects right now?
Are you working in
short periods of time?
So you broken up your
time in the small sprints.
You can't really read it
that well on the slide.
But are you within that short
period of time designing
what you're going to work
on, planning how it's
going to work, doing it, and
then testing it evaluating,
the test and changing it?
Are you doing all that within
one week, or two week cycle?
Raise your hands yea--
so yes, raise your hands.
No, raise your hands.
It's OK if you say no.
OK.
If you're doing something that
looks like this, then great.
And remember, agile, and in
particular, Scrum processes,
they're based on
these three pillars
that Sarah talked about when
we first brought this up.
So the pillar of transparency.
And what we mean by
transparency there,
we really just need a
common nomenclature.
To be honest, I
don't care what you
call the things
that you use as part
of your process in your team.
So long as everyone
within the team
knows what it is, so long
as whoever you're submitting
those processes to
also know who it is.
So we're not acting as your
product owners in the class.
But if you had a
product owner, they
should also know what
you're calling things.
What you're calling
your product backlog,
what you're calling a
task, how you're estimating
and how you're doing
your processes.
So everyone on the team
should know it, not just
in a more traditional manner,
a project manager knowing
what all the processes are.
There's a number of
inspection that's going on.
So through the process,
you are taking a look
at all the artifacts
that you've created.
So those backlog
items, tasks lists,
things like that that you're
creating during the process.
You're inspecting it,
and in particular, you're
inspecting it during meetings.
So you're taking a look at
what you've done in a meeting,
and talking about it.
So you're not just doing a
process, you're doing a process
and you're talking about
it, and you're actively
thinking about the process.
And then you're adapting.
So based on evidence,
based on changes in needs,
you're changing that process.
Again, if you're doing any
one of these three things,
you're doing processes well.
You're doing some form
of agile-like process.
That's another thing I hope
you take from the class.
The agile manifesto.
It is a manifesto,
It is an idea.
It is something that has some
political weight behind it.
It's saying, this is
the way to do things,
this is the right
way to do things.
But it's actually
more vague than that.
It's really just saying,
here are some four key things
that we feel are more important
than other four key things.
So the first item is
individuals and interactions
over processes and tools.
So we've been talking a
lot processes and tools
for the first part
of the semester,
now we're going to talk about
individuals and interactions
between individuals.
So your team members.
All right.
What's a team?
Anybody give me a
working definition
for what you'd call a team.
What'd you say?
AUDIENCE: A bunch
of [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: A bunch of puppies?
Is it a group of people?
Is it just a group of people?
AUDIENCE: A group of people
working toward a common goal.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Anything else?
So it's a collection
of individuals,
so it's a group of people.
They're working toward
a common purpose.
They have shared responsibility
for common outcomes.
If one of those puppies
trips, that stick
goes in another puppy's
mouth, and it hurts a lot.
So keep that in mind.
Shared responsibility, common
purpose, common outcome.
So teams evolve over time.
And the little bit
of research I'm
going to talk about
actually comes
from studying group behaviors.
And this is all from
about 1960s and on up,
and around the 2000s, and
I'll post this reading up.
There were some studies
showing that this actually
works for teams.
This does work for people
who have a common goal.
But as you get a bunch of
people together, and get
a small group of
people together.
And in our terms, we're
calling a small group
of people eight to 10 people.
Maybe a little bit bigger,
but about 10 people total.
They're going to evolve
based on those interpersonal
relationships.
So how they know
each other, what they
talk about, how they talk about.
And their task behaviors.
So we're going to be
talking about not the tasks
that you're doing in your teams,
but the behavior surrounding
the tasks that you're doing it.
So if you're working on a task,
if you are doing some coding,
how are you coding, or
who are you coding with?
How are you talking
to other people
about what you're coding?
And you can apply to
any task that you're
doing in your teams.
There's a lot of
different theories.
Actually, Wikipedia is
a pretty good nutshell
of what are all the
different kinds of theories,
and different kinds
of models we can
use to describe how
groups talk to each other,
and how groups evolve.
But they all come down
to these common things.
There's a period of
getting to know each other,
there's a period of
experiencing conflict,
and there's both positive
and negative conflict when
you're talking with each other.
Your roles shift based on
changing knowledge and changing
experience.
And hopefully at some point,
there's some kind of consensus,
there's some kind
of moving forward.
Decisions happen here.
The point is, though, what
kind of decisions get made?
Are they effective decisions, or
are they ineffective, unproven,
they get made because
you have to make them,
and you have to move on.
And we're hoping that by
analyzing how your teams work,
you can then move towards having
some effective decision making.
So the model we're
going to talk about
is Tuckman's model from '65.
It's got four phases.
Forming, norming,
storming, performing.
It's very cutesy.
It gets used in
training sessions a lot.
It can just be something that
you can just spit out and say,
and someone says, oh, you're
smart, you know that model.
But maybe you don't know
everything behind it.
I might be more in
the you're smart,
but maybe you don't know
everything behind it.
I'm still learning
about how this works.
But each phase has
items you can identify.
More useful for us
is this is a model
you can use to figure out
where your team is right now.
What phase are you in, so
you can then make decisions
about where you need
to go, and how you
need to work together better.
So the forming phase
of it is when you first
are getting together.
Everyone wants to be friendly,
everyone wants to get along
and to be accepted
with each other.
There might be some serious
problems from the get-go,
but they're usually avoided.
And the team learns about
challenges and goals.
But not much gets done.
There's no real task completion
going on in this stage.
When you think about
your previous teams,
you've been in
this stage, right?
When you first got together?
Say project two,
project three, I'm
going to ask you some questions
about projects two and three
as we go forward.
All right.
That's a happy stage.
Then storming happens.
People are able to
express discontent.
There actually might have
been discontent in phase one,
but it actually wasn't being
expressed in some form.
In phase two, it's
being expressed.
But how it's being
expressed can be different.
So it could be someone actively
saying, no, you're wrong,
that's stupid.
It could be someone not talking.
But they're feeling
the same thing,
and they're thinking
about the same thing.
It's the same kind of
disconnect can happen.
Opinions tend to get challenged.
It can be contentious,
it can be unpleasant.
In order to advance past this
stage, what your team really
need is tolerance and patience
just to get through it.
But even more
important, you need
to establish lines of trust
and open communication
to get through this stage.
This is what we've been
doing for the past first
of the semester, is
creating processes.
We've been giving you some
tools that you can use,
so then you can then create
those processes in your teams.
So just a quick hand
raise from teams.
Does anybody think that they're
in this stage right now?
Do you think, in your
team, you are currently,
you're expressing discontent,
you are creating processes,
you don't have processors
yet, but you're figuring out
what your process might be?
Maybe?
What do you say?
You're not sure?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Next u p, norming.
So this is where you
have those processes.
Individuals start giving up
their own ideas and goals.
You're actually moving
toward a team goal right now,
and people are starting
to take responsibility,
and rules are established.
OK.
Comparing storming
to norming, raise
your hands if you think your
team is in norming right now.
OK, yeah.
Now raise your hands if
you think your team is
in storming right now.
OK.
All right, so.
Is anybody performing?
Are you functioning
as a unit efficiently?
Are your team members
already autonomous?
Is descent expected and
addressed right now?
This is where you
want to get to.
You probably aren't
this far yet.
My bet's you're probably
somewhere in the storming area
things, maybe getting close
to the norming area things.
Basically, you're still talking
to each other, you still trying
to figure out what are the
different ways of communicating
with each other.
What are the different processes
and rules you might have.
And you might not get
this far in class,
by the end of the semester.
You might not be fully efficient
by the end of the class,
and that's OK.
But if you are,
it's kind of cool.
So the model in practice
tends to be nonlinear.
It gets talked about, and it
was originally established
as a you go from here, to
here, to here, to here.
You go through the phases,
at the end of the thing,
you're done.
Your team's awesome, go you.
What we Actually
see in process is
that teams tend get in the
forming, they go in the circle
where they go from
having some issues,
figuring out how to
deal with those issues,
establish some rules.
All right, we're going
really well again.
New challenge comes up,
we're back in the storming.
We've put ourselves
in a position where
we don't know how to
talk to each other,
or we don't know how to
communicate with each other.
So there's some
problems with the model.
This is really a
descriptive model.
It's a tool for us to use
to see how things are going.
It's basically a way
to evaluate symptoms.
But there's no
triggers in the model.
We don't know when
those things happen.
When does your team switch
from storming to norming?
So this is what I'd like
you to do in your teams,
just take a couple minutes.
Talk about your previous
teams you've been on,
talk about the
team you're on now.
When do you think your team
would move from stage to stage,
and how could a team
move intentionally?
And in particular,
think about that
storming to norming part of it.
So what is it going to take
for your team right now,
or what happened in your
team right now to go from,
we are having some difficulty
talking with each other,
we have a bunch of opinions,
to we're all on the same page.
Take three minutes.
AUDIENCE: Just one thing
I want to chime in.
There's a very, very good
chance that your team actually
is still in forming stage.
And one of the reasons
why very few of you
might have put up your hands
that you don't actually
want to express dissent,
which is exactly the situation
that you get in
the forming stage.
It is uncomfortable, but
hopefully you can logically
see the benefits of
being in a team where
you can talk about the things
that you disagree with, right?
So it's possible that
you are still in forming,
and it's good to identify
your teams as, OK,
this normal evolution
of a team, and that's
where our team is at right now.
So talk about it
among your team.
PROFESSOR: So take
three minutes,
just talk to your teams.
I'm going to ask you some
questions when we're done.
[SIDE CONVERSATIONS]
So each group, give me
something you talked about about
what are the triggers,
what are the things you
saw as you moved?
Just let me know which
phases you're talking about.
So go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So we have the
answer to [INAUDIBLE].
We're somewhere between
storming and norming.
PROFESSOR: How do you know?
What caused you to
get there, you think?
AUDIENCE: We got a lot of
the core game squared out.
And that was when we
had the most storming.
The reason that I think
we're closer to norming now
is because it's
like past standard.
Pick them up, [INAUDIBLE]
and marking this done.
Which is faster.
On the front end, we're
between forming and storming.
Because we're still working
on a lot of design decisions.
PROFESSOR: All right,
so it's big decisions.
How big are those two teams?
AUDIENCE: Four and four.
PROFESSOR: Four and four?
OK.
So somebody else next.
A trigger that you saw that
made you go from one stage
to the other.
AUDIENCE: I think
as a team, we're
moved from storming to norming.
And part of that
trigger was working
on solidifying our game idea.
Because at this
point, while we all
recognize that we're
building as a team,
we all have different ideas
of what this game should be.
And as we're
solidifying the game,
we're also getting
ourselves in line
with what we're actually doing,
and how we're going to do it.
PROFESSOR: Do you think that
the task of solidifying the game
idea is helping you, because
there's this big decision
you have to make.
Is that helping
you work as a team?
It's not getting in your way?
AUDIENCE: I think it's the
fact that as we're doing this,
we've definitely had this
conflict in our team,
where people were shouting
out different ideas,
and trying to work through it.
And at first, we weren't
doing the best job
of getting those ideas
and working through them.
But I see that now, we're
doing a much better job
of understanding each
other, and seeing how it
fits into the bigger picture.
PROFESSOR: OK, cool.
Next team.
A triggering moment that you saw
in this team or previous teams.
AUDIENCE: So we had a
bigger power team at first,
and I think that having
the sides split up
was the way to help us jump
from forming to storming.
Because we had to
use scripts in order
to get our team to get to ideas.
Also, there were
conflicting ideas
in terms of where ideas go
in the brainstorming session.
PROFESSOR: So it's basically
just reducing the number
of opinions, really, right?
When that is purely
through people.
AUDIENCE: So with our game,
I think getting us to norming
was really-- you talked
about assigning tasks.
But also just the
accountability aspect,
because instead of
spending time arguing,
we had a designated
person, or a couple people
who are capable for
different things.
Which allows us to just
not argue [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So like
certain people
have different they
own some subtasks,
or their own subroles?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Cool.
In the back?
What do you think?
AUDIENCE: I guess what
got us over to storming
was meeting together as a team
to make design decisions, which
was like what has
been said there.
And I think that the next step
for bringing us over to norming
would be actually
getting everyone
to participate in
design decisions.
Because people have both not
shown up, and not particularly
shown interest in
getting things going.
So having everyone on
board is [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So that's a big one.
That's a huge
difficulty, especially
with student projects.
You've got all these other
things going on around you.
Do you think you need everyone
to contribute to the design,
or do you need everyone to
be on board with the design?
AUDIENCE: So I understand
some people are just
less interested in having deep
discussions about the design
of the game, but
getting everyone
to both be aware and willing to
participate when they need to.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Because yeah, there's
important conversations
being done that, if they're
not there when it happens,
they're not going to know where
the status of the game is.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
They just need to be
willing to participate.
If they're not there,
take the step of, oh,
what'd you guys talk about?
I'm interested in knowing.
PROFESSOR: Thank
you for that lead,
because that gets us
to our next stage.
So I think we find ourselves
talking a lot about the product
that we're making.
It's just easier.
It's that hard
thing you can see.
It's being made,
it's being done.
We can play it.
It means we're probably
doing something right.
But it's still very difficult
to talk about the people.
But we saw been talking
about the people a little bit
here, especially with
accountability in this one.
It was good.
Cool.
So that brings me
to the next topic.
Teams are composed
of individuals,
and each person on
your team is going
to have a lot of different
factors affecting
what they do, how they
do it, when they do it.
I can't give you the magic
formula to get them motivated.
What I can do is show you
some of the different ways
that you can try to either
understand the people you're
with, understand the
people on your team,
or find things to
talk to them about.
You might notice a
number of these things.
So to get someone
who's motivated,
someone who's going to
be able to participate,
think about all these things.
Think about personal
development.
So you're in a
class, you're here
hopefully because
you want to learn.
You want to learn a new skill,
you want to try a new skill.
Everyone wants to
learn a new skill.
There might be a skill that they
want to work on on your team,
and I think we've
talked about that
in the past when we were talking
about the vision statement,
and people putting down why
they're involved on the team,
and why they're involved
in this project.
So being aware of that,
and constantly coming back
to that for each person,
especially if you have someone
on your team who is
just not participating,
and you need to figure
out how to engage them.
Think about the
skills that they want
to bring to the
table, the skills
they're trying to practice.
When it comes to
motivation, it largely
comes down to
intrinsic or extrinsic.
The extrinsic might be the
grade that they're going to get,
but it's really difficult
to really hone in on that,
because the grade's
shared between your group.
So that might not be
the place to look at.
Try to take a look at
the intrinsic things.
If they had enthusiasms about
the project at some point,
try to remember what that was.
Ask somebody else on your team
what that might have been.
See if you can bring
that enthusiasm back
into the project.
Morale or self-worth.
There's been some
research that shows
that the reason why people work
well on teams, and the reason
why we want to work on teams
is because it brings us
self-worth.
And in particular, there's
some self awareness
that can happen by being
on a team, and getting--
and actually, it links a little
bit to extrinsic rewards.
By getting rewarded, getting
feedback on my performance,
it's going to help me do better.
Empowerment, giving ownership.
So raise your hands if your team
uses assigning tasks or taking
tasks.
So assigning tasks,
raise your hand.
If your team assigns
tasks to individuals.
That team.
Kind of?
Yeah.
You assign, so there's
one person on your team
that says you are
going to do this.
Has anybody tried
ownership, where
someone takes a task from a set
of tasks that are available?
Little, little.
When does that work?
When does ownership work?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
What's that?
AUDIENCE: When people
are eager to work,
and they're interested
in what we're doing.
PROFESSOR: So there's some
of those other things.
There's some enthusiasm over it.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: It's usually a while
before the deadline, too.
PROFESSOR: OK, cool.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: You can
run into problems
if you say who's going to do
this, and nobody volunteers.
So my experience has
been that it's good
if people can volunteer
for tasks that they're
enthusiastic about, but then,
if nobody will volunteer
to do something that needs to
be done, someone has to step up
and say, OK, you're
going to do this.
So it's like kind of
a hybrid [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So where
does-- yeah, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
and I think also,
it depends on if
everyone on a team
is willing to take ownership
versus, like, only some people.
Because that'll create
a different dynamic.
There's some people who are
really taking initiative,
but the others aren't,
so you're still going
to need to assign them tasks.
So I think something
that's where
at the beginning ask for
people to take ownership,
and then the tasks
that are left,
there's one person who's
going to delegate this out.
PROFESSOR: So at the beginning,
everybody takes on tasks.
And at the end, when
you have the leftovers,
they get assigned.
Yeah, Matt?
AUDIENCE: One of
the biggest problems
I've seen with this is
when you're not thinking
about the game you
are working on,
especially this is
very easy since we have
a lot of other work, then things
can stall, because you're not
thinking about
what kind of game,
so you're not thinking
about being passive.
PROFESSOR: So you might not
actually have ownership.
It might look like
you had ownership.
There is the
evidence of ownership
in that someone said,
OK, I'll take that task.
But there's no follow through,
there's no commitment.
And that gets to the
next one, commitment.
The best way to have commitment
on your team is for one person
to be committed to
express that commitment,
to express that loyalty.
For everyone else
to see that loyalty
and see that
commitment, and then
hopefully they pick up the
ball, and they're like, OK,
I'm going to be committed, too.
If that second person
doesn't do that, pick it up,
then it doesn't travel
through the chain,
it just doesn't happen.
Even though that
one person went out
of their way to show
that kind of sacrifice,
it just didn't get picked up.
Do see that chain
happening on your teams,
do you see it breaking?
Can you identify where
that breaking point is,
and can you think
about ways to fix that?
Trust is a big one.
So raise your hands
if you have worked
with the majority of
people on your team
before, in some fashion.
This class or other classes.
You feel like you
know your teammates.
Raise your hands if you
feel like you really
know your teammates, you've
worked with them before.
High if you really think so.
So one, two, maybe.
One, two, three.
So think about how well
you know each other,
think about ways you
can figure out how
you can know each other better.
Social interactions.
Going out for coffee, going out
for lunch, things like that.
Is there something that
you can do that will
help that kind of thing happen?
And then here's the big one,
this is the MIT one, stress.
Stress tends to be the negative.
It can be positive, in that
it's the end of the project,
and it's due, and you just
need to get things done,
and that could lead to crunch.
But then there's also the huge
negative aspect of stress,
and that's very much an external
factor, for the most part.
It could be in an
internal factor.
If there's some stress being
caused by internal things
going on with your team,
it's likely related
to one of the ones above it.
So one way to think
about these 7 things,
you can think of them in
terms of the desirability
to learn new skills, or the
desirability to take on task.
So if you're trying to
come up with strategies
with your team on how to
solve some of these problems,
think of it in those two terms.
So how do distributed
teams perform?
So what do I mean
by distributed?
What is a distributed team?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Chopped up into
groups, and each group
is working on its own secret?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Or just everyone's
all over the place.
It could mean that
you are in Singapore,
and someone else is in Ohio.
You could be separated
by time zones, by oceans.
And really, I think that might
be east campus and MacGregor,
maybe.
It could just be
through distance,
it could be through your
schools, could be through
your departments,
your majors, whatnot.
There's some kind of boundaries
going on between people.
In this case, it's largely time.
Some people can work
during some hours,
some people can't work
during those hours.
So what have you done
so far to fix that?
And think back on the
postmortems you've given us.
What are some of the strategies
you've already used and seen
used to figure out how to work
across different time periods?
AUDIENCE: Well, right
now, we're using Slacked,
which is pretty helpful.
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: What's it called?
AUDIENCE: Slacked.
It's like Flowdock.
PROFESSOR: It's like what?
AUDIENCE: Flowdock.
PROFESSOR: What's that?
AUDIENCE: It's group
instant messaging.
PROFESSOR: Yay.
AUDIENCE: And it keeps track
of all our assigned tasks.
And also, [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Cool. anybody else
using group IM, or an IRC chat?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: We're using
something called [INAUDIBLE],
which is like a chat
tied to your GitHub.
PROFESSOR: Cool.
AUDIENCE: I think
Skype also just allows
communication [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Cool.
OK.
It's great when it can
hook up to the things,
and it works with your workflow.
It's also just great
to have just period.
If you don't use any of those,
maybe think about Skype.
Any other things people use?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: In my
experience, let's say
we're working on something,
and [INAUDIBLE] at that point.
It would be good to keep
the whole team informed
of all the programs, what's
happening on your grant.
So we really like to just use
a Google Doc explaining exactly
what you have done so far.
PROFESSOR: So reporting.
I remember some people
had issues with email
on previous teams.
So anybody still using
email as a primary
means of communication
on your team?
How's it working
for y'all so far?
AUDIENCE: It hasn't gotten
to the hectic point yet.
We think we started talking
about emailing subgroups more,
except [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yep.
Are those emails going to
be archived and viewable
by everyone at a later date?
AUDIENCE: That would
be a good idea.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
And I think that's why we
tend to think about group IMs.
And particularly, Philip likes
IRC for that very reason.
Certain IRC servers will
keep an archive for you.
Other kinds of groupware
will do that too,
but they tend to be pricey.
Has anybody started using
Trello on your teams yet?
Yeah?
Are you using it as a
communication method,
or as a recording of things?
AUDIENCE: Recording of things.
PROFESSOR: Anybody using that as
a communication method at all?
Trying that out.
Because I think it can do
email notifications and things
like that when things change.
Assigning members to
tasks, stuff like that.
All right.
So again, we got
talking into tools.
What other things can we do?
So another paper that it's going
to be on Stellar if you want
to look at it was
basically a survey
of distributed teams
using agile processes,
and giving up some
best practices of what
worked best for them.
And I was nice, and I'm just
give you the summary of that.
So one thing they noticed
is having a one team mindset
was the thing that got them
through working together
as a group.
What do we mean by one team?
That the group first
identifies as a team,
like what we talked
about before.
They all have a goal that
they're going towards,
they all identify as
going towards that goal.
They don't identify as
just an individual group.
But that's actually a major
part of their identity.
For them, it's because that's
their 40 hour, 80 hour, 120
hour work weeks.
Something I think
you you're going
to have an issue with,
because you're working
smaller periods of time.
But the way they're able
to do that is they've
got these frequent
team interactions.
And actually, when
they're working
for a long period
of time, there are
people who are
working on their own
in their home or
their home office
with another team
that's very far away.
And yet, these teams
still do a daily stand up.
Does anybody here do a daily
stand up on their teams
right now?
So what they're doing is
they're going on video,
they're talking to each other
for a very short period of time
about what they've done,
what they're going to do,
what's in their way.
The cool thing with
daily stand ups,
and why they think
this works for them,
it goes back to
those seven items
I listed about how you get
people engaged on a team?
It shows commitment.
The fact that there are people
who are showing up to meetings.
There's some kind of
personal sacrifice.
Some people are meeting at a
very strange hour of the day
that they're not
normally going to meet,
and they're doing that
because of the team.
They're sacrificing something
personal for the team.
Everyone else on the
team sees that, they
see that kind of commitment.
They feel like they need to
reflect that back themselves.
Also trust.
And in this
particular case, it's
the trust of not letting
meetings take too long.
These daily stand ups really
should only take 10 minutes.
An effective team
can do it in five.
An effective 10 person team.
30 seconds each, go, everyone
says what they've done.
Everyone sees each
other's faces.
The great thing about
seeing each other's faces
is you can see what stage of
fear and anxiety they're in.
And you can then
talk to them later,
and have some other personal
interactions with them.
The other thing they do,
they do co-located work.
They've got money
sometimes, so they're
flying people back and forth.
But again, they're also
doing co-located work
by doing things, having Skype
always on in the background
while they're working together.
But they're not doing
it the entire time,
they can't afford that.
So one thing you can do is to
schedule your co-located time
at the beginning of the
project, which is basically
what we've been doing in
class for the past few weeks.
Identifying important
milestones, and making sure
you've scheduled a co-located
period during that milestone,
right before that milestone
is going to help you greatly.
Doing insert teams,
and doing video chat.
And here's a big one we haven't
talked about in class so much,
but I get the impression
that some of you
might be interested
in this kind of thing.
Having coaches.
So we've already seen
some of the teams
have a dedicated scrum
master or producer.
Think about having
a dedicated coach.
So someone who's
on your team, who's
there to cultivate team spirit.
They're going to emphasize
the importance of one team.
They could be your scrum
master or producer,
but they're not
actually the same role.
The scrum master or the producer
is measuring productivity.
They're measuring tasks on
how well things get done.
The coach is very different.
They're looking at how people
interact with each other,
how people talk to each other.
How people work with each other.
Oftentimes, people who are
naturally inclined to do one
can be inclined to do the other,
but that's not always the case.
So if you have
someone on your team
who is one of those extroverted,
outgoing, or even introverted
but really interested in what
individuals do one-on-one,
and how individuals work.
See if you can incorporate
some coaching strategies
with your teammates.
And again, you can do
one-on-one meetings,
and we can talk about
this in the future
if you're interested
in this kind of stuff.
We can unpack on this topic
and talk about it further.
But I highly recommend it.
So I did mention meetings.
You do have agile
meetings, these people
have agile meetings.
These are what they are.
So who has a formal sprint
process, where you plan
your sprint before you start?
So you basically create your
sprint task list at a meeting?
Is everyone there?
Not everyone's there.
AUDIENCE: We have the tasks,
and we've focused [INAUDIBLE].
So we do have a formal
week-by-week, here's
what we want to
get done this week.
PROFESSOR: OK, cool.
And you had a meeting
to create that?
Then you have your
daily stand ups.
At the end of the sprint, you
want to have a sprint review.
Just basically the inverse of
the sprint planning meeting.
You go back and
see what you made.
Hopefully, you have a build
and you just basically
look at the build, compare the
build to the completed tasks,
and make sure it matches.
The other meeting that you
may or may not be doing
is the agile retrospective.
And that's how did
you work this week?
Is anybody doing
that, is anybody
at the end of their
sprint, talking
about the processes of what
you did and how you did it?
OK.
It's what I expect.
I think you're doing
yourself a disservice
if you're not doing that.
And particularly, if
you are doing that
and you're making that
a face to face meeting,
that's the time when
you can talk about some
of these interpersonal issues.
That's the time
when you can talk
about your feelings, that's
the time when you can open up,
and try to figure
out what is about,
why are some of these
tasks not getting taken on,
who's not doing them, and what's
in their way from doing them.
But really, it's not really
about what's in the way,
it's difficult to talk about.
It's not about
what's in their way,
but it might be
about what outside
of the project and outside of
the team could be in their way?
And can you work through
some of those issues?
So I'm done.
What I'd like you do before
you go and work in your teams
is schedule a sprint
retrospective.
So take a look at
your sprint process.
How long is your sprint?
Is it one week or two weeks?
We've been assuming
it's one-week sprints.
Schedule a time period
that everyone can attend,
and an amount of time
that they can attend.
That they can see
each other face
to face, but not necessarily
are in the same room.
If they can be in the
same room, awesome.
If you can't, try
to figure out a time
that you can chat using Google
Hangout, or some other kind
of face to face video chat.
Make sure the meeting
is focused on talking
about your processes.
So don't talk about your game,
don't talk about the work
that you've done.
Talk about how you
organized yourself.
And in particular, talk about
your interpersonal matters.
Basically, communicate
about communicating.
So talk about how you're
talking to each other.
And yeah, I want to talk to you
about this again in a couple
weeks.
I think most of you
right now are probably
in the concepting phase,
pre-production phase right now.
You're still figuring
out your game,
you haven't quite-- I
guess you guys are actually
working on your back
end, because someone
did the initial design for you.
The rest are probably still
working out the design phase.
When I talk about
this again, you'll
likely be in full-on
production mode,
and so some of the activities
I'm going to show you
might hopefully help when
you're doing these meetings.
Any questions?
OK.
So it's 1:50.
Go ahead and take a
few minutes to break,
and then the rest of the class
is yours to work in your teams.
But still do this.
[SIDE CONVERSATIONS]